I appreciated the fact that, uh, you know, recently on social media,
you started engaging politically. You were like, look,
this stuff's kind of important.
Like I know some of you might not love everything,
but let's like actually talk things out and like, uh, you know,
be reasonable human beings, which, you know, I completely agree with.
Yes. But it's difficult to get like,
even people who agree with you and you're just like, here's this point.
And even people with agreed, like, yeah, cause those cry lives blew it.
It's like, no, no, no, listen, man, like this one point is good.
And then tomorrow Trump's going to have a middle piece, middle East peace deal.
That's the kind of, got to say is, okay, you can't just say it's bad.
You know what I mean? And it's so like,
and even if someone agrees with me with like just rhetoric or negative,
they don't get the hell out of here. Let's all talk, go yell at everybody else.
You go yell at Trump's Twitter feed. If you're here,
we're all going to engage in some talking. And uh,
I took a little break because it was really hard to have a conversation. And,
and I, I have no hard feelings. Like I have a heart of stone.
I don't give a about anything. When I went to says about like, if it's a good,
if you zing me or make fun of me in a good way,
like go lose some more matches or something like you get me, I get it.
It's funny. Uh, but I want it to be good entertaining, and I want it to be,
I want both of them, there should be more than two sides,
but that's a whole other conversation,
but I want it to be human beings engaging and not just
be so mad that they want to go out in the streets or wish death on somebody
talking about politics.
Um, I don't disagree that we need a different level of dynamism in our political
system. Uh, that right now the duopoly is not great for.
[Inaudible]. I hate it.
Well, even as the numbers guy, uh,
I think the last numbers I saw 30% of Americans,
I self-identified as Democrats,
maybe 25% Republicans and then 40%
independence. And so you look up and say, well, that's quite a,
quite a great deal of people that self identify as independence. Uh,
and then when it comes to this sort of election, everyone's like, well,
you got these two choices and you're like, like, is it like,
how did this happen? Uh, again, um,
so to me, the path forward, um,
is to have rank choice voting so that they're just different points of view
reflected. And you don't have anyone bullying, anyone saying like,
can't waste your vote. Can't waste your vote. Now, like in this circumstance,
I'm like, you know, everyone knows I'm for Joan Camilla,
and I think Trump needs to go. Um,
but I also think that the fact that we have, um,
we have so many Americans who are just like, ah, like, you know, I,
I feel like my vote doesn't matter because by the time it gets to me,
I'm like choosing between, uh, people that I would not have chosen, um,
is not good for democracy. It's not good for the country.
And it's like that Simpsons episode where it's like, uh,
the two monster space monsters come and land. And he goes,
we got to pick from one of us, one of us, the Republican ones Democrat.
And he goes, I'm going to vote third party. And he goes, go ahead,
throw your vote away. And it's like, and then the next,
they're all enslaved in camps. And it's like, it's the Monster's rule the world.
And it's,
it's so heartbreaking because I know that there's a lot of
similarities on both sides to where that is, that, that middle ground,
that 40% of people who want something else,
but tend to agree with 95% of everything on the sides and all day
long, we and find these straw men have like this fridge, right.
Or fringe left that we can go see, they're all just like that. And you know,
and it's, it's,
it's disheartening because I I've been around a little bit and I've seen things
happen.
And I kind of know that it's a show and a game and you're getting things done
and you're going back and forth.
But young kids today who are online all the time,
think that Twitter is real and this is how it goes.
And this is life. And one, it's not accurate.
That's like 5% of the world is on Twitter and everyone else is doing real life
things. And if you just go,
I'm so mad at Ben Shapiro right now and you go outside and you're like,
he has nothing to do with you gardening in your backyard.
But like folks who have to interact with groups of Americans in real
life, in different parts of the country, uh, in bars, clubs,
wrestling, arenas, autograph sessions, it's like,
you have a very different sense of this country and of human beings
then, uh, just like turning on TV and being like, Oh,
these people that people cause like you've actually met thousands and thousands
of people, uh, in, uh, you know, in, in their everyday lives.
And then the characters don't really stand up. I mean,
certainly I had that experience running cause like I met,
I've met thousands and thousands of people.
Like you. Yeah. You, I mean, I'm somewhat,
I've been around some people in bands that, but you just like two years ago,
like how does that you all of a sudden, no 5 million people and you go,
Oh right.
People are for the most part decent and want the same thing and whatever
conversation and how cool is it to be,
don't want to shake your hand back when you were on to shake hands.
Well, uh, you know, I'm happy to say Nick,
that I kind of assumed that most people were, uh,
pretty reasonable and we just wanted the best things for themselves and their
family. So it wasn't like when I went on to the country,
I discovered it was more like I confirmed what I already knew
because I grew up in a town and like,
I remember the kids I grew up with and like, you know, like,
did we do some dumb that, you know,
like if you were to paint it now and like social media, like, you know, like,
uh, like, would it look terrible? Sure. Like, are those people, are,
are those people, um, somehow terrible human beings? Of course not like,
you know, we're just like, we're like, um, teenage idiots,
like it was a different, and we were lucky to.
Have that non social media world and non camera world.
And you have to do stupid stuff as a kid.
And then the point is you grow and then everybody wins.
I,
and sometimes I feel that people don't want you to grow.
They want to make an example of something, uh, and go, Oh,
you didn't tell him for this properly, this thing he did 20 years ago.
And you go, ah, that sucks. Um, but I did, I'm talking to you right now.
Doesn't this count as me growing like, Nope.
Okay.
I, again, people are so much more reasonable in person and online it's like,
like if you were to stick two people in a room, it's like,
they would not say 90% of like the nasty things that they'll like put in a
social media post. This is not the way people are the,
that they interact. Um, so I get the sense, um,
from this conversation that if you were to describe yourself politically,
it would be something of an independent where you, you see things, uh,
um, in a non-partisan way. Is that accurate?
Uh, yeah, very much. So I go out of my way to do that. Um, I lead a little bit,
right. Uh, I like lower taxes. I lean a little bit. Right. Um,
I, I, I've done some stuff with, uh,
Fox and Fox business and even the people on the left who have been on panels
with me, like, they're fantastic. They're so smart. I love it. Uh, but I,
I lead a little bit. Right. And, uh, I, uh, but every issue,
I don't just go down the line and go, this is it. And put the yard sign out.
Like I want to examine every issue. And I feel like what you mentioned earlier,
there's that 40% of people who have this don't really totally relate to a
party,
but we want this general idea and they're not really spoken to as much.
And I feel like there's that huge middle and I don't want to,
I'm an independent, cause I hate every, the two candidates. That's not the case.
I just, I lean. Right. And uh,
I want more people to meet in the middle and I am very pro third-party let
alone frigging 20 parties to just give people some different options, you know?
Yeah. I think the path to a third party really is a different voting system,
like rank choice voting because you know, like it's,
instead of case where the mechanics actually make a world of difference,
like if you give people the ability to vote their preference, uh,
and there's no, there's no pressure to, you know, again,
like avoid quote unquote wasting your vote and the rest of it. Um, uh, the,
the reality is that both party registrations are actually declining over time.
You know, neither Republicans nor Democrats are, uh, in growth positions, uh,
in that way. And so to me, like if you're,
uh, if you're pro democracy,
but also even if you're a pro these parties trying to become more responsive to
people and maybe even resuming, um, like a growth position, um,
then they need to try and engage with different types of,
and have different types of ideas in that.
That was one of the reasons why I ran, um,
is that I thought the democratic party could use some new ideas, uh,
including universal basic income, which strikes me as not terribly, um,
left or right. Like it's just.
UBI. I was going to bring it up. Relax. I know, I know the deal.
Well, thank you, Nick. Look at that.
I, why do you think, uh, UN AOC in 2028, all this stuff I have all these notes.
No, I think that's that idea. Shouldn't be,
I don't want you to sound this wrong. Like, I shouldn't be a crazy idea to go.
We can't try this thing where you don't trust the government and you're sick of
them ruining your money.
We can't trust the people with it just one time and see if the hell happens.
Like w we, we tried out Trump,
like we wanted an outsider.
Why your idea should not be a crazy idea. When we give,
we waste money in the government so much,
they mismanagement mismanagement a lot and you know, let's give you,
we, you met all these people. You see that for the most part. They're good.
They want to do better people. Some people are going to blow it. Sure.
But that's life, you know what I mean?
Give them a chance because the government is going to blow most of it anyway.
So let's get a shot, you know?
Yeah.
We just lived at two when people got this $1,200 stimulus check back in April
and I dare say it was awesome. Like, people, people loved it.
Yeah. Know people, people like did what they did, but, uh, but, but,
but by the numbers, like, you know,
it worked like there was a study that came out afterwards and it made me laugh,
Nick. It was like, like giving people a $1,200 reduced poverty. And I was like,
yeah, it, it really did like great, great work.
Um, so, so yeah, like I, I think, uh,
I mean right now, um,
something like 75% of Americans are pro cash relief during the pandemic,
including majority of Republicans, I never contact. Everyone's like, look,
this is common sense. Everyone's on board with us.
It just seems like the elections in coming up.
So we all have to fight about if you can get $150 or $450,
but nobody wants to lose points politically,
which this is that part of the game where it's like, guys,
people are going to vote for Trump or buy it in how it's going to go give these
people a couple hundred dollars for having to sit at home and shut down their
business. Like, come on.
Thank you for listening in. I hope you enjoyed this conversation. If you did,
please do subscribe to yang,
speaks and click on notifications so we can let you know every time we have a
new episode.